and somebody else who is looking great
these days Oprah she is lost 126 pounds
and here's something we're all excited
about Oprah is acting in a TV series the
first time she's acted on TV since the
80s and she invited me to Atlanta to
spend the day with her at work oh my
gosh it's so good this time brother
it's her first recurring TV role since
1990s Brewster place in Greenleaf she's
a boozy blues club owner with a potty
mouth about blues diddly-doo or squat
about blue you know she uses f-bombs a
couple of times and so is that hard for
you to actually have to spit out an
f-bomb not really I use an f-bomb once
and Stedman said I will die I'm not
gonna stand here and listen to that kind
of language I wasn't even talking to him
and believe it or not acting makes Oprah
nervous it's act enough to really feel
like comfortable with it it's always
like oh god you know I got it do that
thing the church did that to them that's
what I'm trying to say and as an
executive producer she gets to call the
shots dude I love the casting process I
love getting the little clips of people
in there auditioning just like being
involved I like being the own series is
centered around the scandals and sins at
the less than virtuous a Greenlee family
and their Memphis mega church anytime
that you do something about religion
there's always controversy that will
spur any worries I am never going to be
disrespectful to the church I can tell
you that I'm never going to be
disrespectful because it is the rock and
the foundation of Who I am now would I
use it as a basis for telling stories
about people who are flawed yeah but I'm
not gonna do anything to disrespect you
how come you've been so hard to get
ahold of lately and a perk of being the
EP she chose pal Regina King who is
directed scandal to direct an episode of
green leaves
I guess maybe I should say action on
this on it yes you should it has given
me great great great empathy for the
people who do this every day
III I'm not cut out for it I got to tell
you yeah I like the ability to be able
to fire myself yeah I doubt that's gonna
happen cuz Oprah's pretty much as close
to perfect as you can get well the Oprah
could fire her okay yeah well actually
it happened back in her 20s she told me
which is a great evening news reporter
in Baltimore but in true Oprah fashion
she said that it only makes her stronger